In Afghanistan, more than 100 members of the Afghan security forces...
...were reported killed when Taliban insurgents...
...attacked a military compound in the central Maidan Wardak province.
At least 89 people in Mexico are confirmed dead after a fuel pipeline explosion.
President Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador promises an investigation.
Ten Chadian peacekeepers were killed and at least 25 others injured...
...during an Al-Qaida in the Islamic Maghreb attack...
...on a UN camp in northern Mali.
In Ethiopia, hundreds of thousands of Ethiopian Orthodox worshippers...
...came together in the capital, Addis Ababa, over the weekend...
...to celebrate Epiphany,...
...a festival that commemorates the baptism of Jesus Christ.
Finally from Venezuela,...
...protests begin outside the National Guard headquarters...
...in support of arrested rebel soldiers...
...who posted an appeal for public support in a video.